So I knew you were coming in to do some filming.
And I was wondering into work thinking about what to talk about and it was
raining and I was getting a bit wet. But as I was wondering along,
I just cited idly thinking about rain. And in particular,
why is that raindrops are kind of that big, rather than that big,
I guess it sort of starts by what size his raindrops actually are.
And in particular fact that they're not actually all the same size.
There is a distribution of raindrop size. And in fact, the,
some of the early work on this was done by a guy called Wilson Bentley.
He was a fascinating guy. He was kind of a, an autodidact.
He taught himself all the science. He did, he was fascinated by science. Uh,
he was a farmer from Vermont at the beginning of the 20th century. And, uh,
he was really interested in things that fell out of the sky. So for example,
he made sort of the definitive set of photographs of snowflakes and was really
the person who showed that snowflakes of all different shapes.
But one of the other things he looked at was rain and he measured with a rather
elegant experiment,
the sizes of the drops that fall out of the sky in different types of rainfall.
Um, so he'd had this very neat experiment. He took a, uh, a tray full of flour.
So it sort of fairly shallow layer of flour in a tray and just put it out in the
rain for a couple of seconds, pulled it back in again.
And so the raindrops would kind of fall in and soak some of the flour.
He then wait for the little pellet.
So it kind of formed out of that to dry and then pick them out of the flour.
And then the sizes of the pellets told them about the size of the raindrops.
In a ratio, or were they the same, like.
I think sort of coincidentally, they turn out to be, so he,
he did the proper thing. So it was, you know,
the scientific experiments is you then calibrate your results.
So he actually took drops of known size and drop them from varying Heights into
flour and found out what sizes of pellets they made.
And he found that basically the size of the pellets corresponded almost exactly
to the size of the drop that fell in, in the first place.
So just by measuring this, the sort of size distribution of the pellets,
he was able to find out about the size distribution of rain.
I actually have his paper here.
So here's his paper where he explains his experiment and so on,
but he actually has photographs of some of his experiments showing what the
raindrops look like. And you can see, again,
this is sort of ranges of different sizes, some little drops, some big drops,
but he also found that sometimes the size distribution was more uniform.
Sometimes there were bigger drops. Sometimes there were smaller drops. Um,
so he basically found that the, the, as a rule of thumb, the heavier,
the rain was the bigger the drops are. Um, but beyond that,
he quite found quite a variety of different outcomes.
He was indeed the pioneer in this and people then went on to make more
quantitative measurements and sort of studied findings of empirical rules.
So here's a paper gave him one of the definitive papers on this,
which is actually only one page long by Marshall and Palmer in 1948.
And what they found is that with different rates of rainfall.
So this is the sort of the number of drops versus drop size.
So what they found is that there were lots of little drops and then many fewer
bigger drops. And in fact, this is a log scale up here. So this is actually,
you know,
this is a hundred times as many drops this size as they're all this size.
So it's, this is actually because this out as a straight line on this scale,
that means it's actually an exponential distribution.
There are lots and lots of little ones and not very many big ones.
It's always follows the same kind of distribution,
but the sort of calibration of it depends on how heavy the rainfall is that in,
in heavier rain, you get bigger drops.
There's something very beautiful about like just humans studying rain. It is,
although it actually, it turns out it has application it's two. So for example,
one of the issues about a radio wave propagation. So if you're trying to, uh,
broadcast radio, or if you've got radar it's affected by raindrops,
and it depends on the size distribution of the raindrops and actually the shapes
of the raindrops as well.
So there is actually a sort of a practical application,
as well as it just being an interesting thing to find out about the world.
So now we need to sort of get to the bottom of why raindrops are the size they
are and why they grow to a certain size and no bigger,
which means we kind of need to go back and look at the physics a bit more about
how raindrops grow in the first place. Okay,
so you have a cloud and a raindrop will start to form. And really,
so this is a sort of a cloud of water vapor, and it's going to start condensing.
So to start condensing,
typically you need something which sort of seeds the condensation.
So it's thought that just a tiny little grain of dust or something is there in
the cloud, which water then will start to settle on.
So you start forming a drop and that drop will grow. There'll be more, you know,
more water will,
will grow onto that drop and also drops will crash into each other.
So they'll grow both by sort of, uh, creating stuff from the vapor,
but also by smashing into each other and growing into bigger drops that way.
And as they start to grow, they start out as completely round.
And the physics as to why they're completely round is to do with surface
tension, the surface tension sort of pools the thing into an interest sphere.
It, maybe I should draw a picture for this. Can I draw a picture? Yeah,
let's have a picture. A water molecule fits in the middle of the water.
It's surrounded by lots of other water molecules and they're all pulling it
towards them.
And so basically there's no net force on our water molecule in the middle here.
But if you get near the surface, you got a water molecule, you here,
then there's more molecules below it than there are above it.
And that means there's a sort of imbalanced force.
There's more things pulling it downwards than the wall pulling it outwards.
So if you can imagine trying to take an individual water molecule and pull it up
to the surface that in here, you can move it around how you like,
but as you get close to the surface,
the other water molecule was trying to pull it back down again.
So you actually have to do some work to get it up near the surface.
You actually having to fight quite hard to get it to the surface.
That actually means there's energy stored in the water molecules closer to the
surface. And so the more surface area you have, the more energy,
potential energy there is stored up there.
And nature being kind of lazy prefers to have the lowest energy state.
And so therefore the lowest energy state for any, uh,
collection of water is the one that minimizes the amount of energy stored near
the surface,
which means you basically want to minimize the surface area of the object and
for any given blob of water, the shape, which minimizes the surface energy,
energy as a sphere.
And so that's why small amounts of water will arrange themselves into spheres
because surface tension makes that the lowest energy and that's,
so that's how it ends up being.
Does that mean we need a seed like a,
as a grain of dust or something for every raindrop.
There has to be yes, because the raindrops have to know where to form.
So there's something special about that place,
which of which the simplest thing is just a tiny little grain of dust,
probably microscopic in size,
but there's just something up there which makes it seed at that particular
point. Okay. So you made your job.
It starts out being spherical because because of the surface tension effects,
it's then starting to fall.
And that means that basically from the raindrops perspective,
the air is kind of rushing up past it. And at that point,
we have to start worrying about aerodynamics.
Now we made a whole video about Lyft and aerodynamics and what have you.
And perhaps the only lesson from that is that aerodynamics is really rather
complicated.
And this is even more complicated because it's not like a wing or it's something
like that, which is a fixed shape. This is a raindrop,
which means that as the air rushes past it, it can rearrange it shape.
So not only do you have to worry about the flow of air,
but you have to worry about what it's doing to the shape of the object.
Like a wing made of jelly.
Exactly. And not surprisingly, you know,
you've got quite a lot of air pressure and things happening.
It will all deformed and you'll end up with, uh, with the thing,
no longer being.
That's where we get a beautiful raindrop shape from it.
Sadly not though. So you think so because you know,
raindrop nice era for your shape,
it turns out that it's not the shape you end up with.
And although the physics is really rather complicated,
there's a quite a simple way to think about it,
which is that as the thing is falling,
this kind of air pressure from its perspective, it's being pushed from below.
And so what the simplest thing that starts to happen is it just starts to
flatten at the bottom. And so now the air keeps flying around it,
but now it's got to kind of got a flat bottom to it.
So it's like a hamburger buns shape.
It ends up being sort of still round on the top of that flat on the bottom.
So then that process sort of continues. The pressure below keeps going.
And what happens is it actually starts to the bottom starts, isn't even flat.
It starts to turn a concave. Um, and at that point,
air kind of gets trapped inside the thing.
And your whole raindrop actually blows up like a little balloon with a kind of a
ring of water at the bottom of it.
And then not surprisingly that surface tension is not enough to hold the thing
together. And then it bursts into a thousand little fragments.
So you can't actually have a big raindrop because it's unstable in that way.
The air pressure will kind of blow it up and make it exploded.
[Inaudible].
Almost acting like a parachute.
It is. Yeah. And so let me show you a picture. These really are fascinating,
cute things. So here's some experiments.
And so this is still an active area of research. This is a, an, uh,
an article in nature physics,
which is one of the more prestigious journals in physics from 2009.
And so here's the picture. Here's our large raindrop starting to fall.
It gets flatter as it falls.
Then you can see at some point it actually starts to inflate this little bag
forms above it. The surface tension holds it together for a little while,
then it bursts in the hole. And then the,
actually the ring that's left behind fragments as well.
And you end up with many, many tiny fragments.
So at what point in the journey are we, is, is it still up in the cloud here?
Has it fallen 10 miles? Like what, how long does this take?
It depends how big, how quickly it goes Briggs. So if you have a rain drop,
that goes big very quickly. This happens very early on.
If you have a raindrops which stay small, this process will never happen.
It'll actually just stay sort of raindrop shaped and keep falling. Um,
so it really is when the things grow above a millimeter or so in size,
that's when this, these processes start to happen.
When they shatter into lots of small fragments, what happens to those fragments?
So in principle, if there was time, the whole process, we start all over again,
and it was thought that they would start growing again. The interesting thing,
and the point of this paper actually is that the distribution of these fragment
sizes is exactly the same as the distribution that these guys
found of what was actually hitting the ground.
So the hypothesis they come up with this and in this paper,
is that actually what happens is that the,
that this process only happens once that the rain large raindrop forms,
it shatters into this distribution of smaller fragments.
And those are the things which fall on your head at the ground level.
And that then the size distribution of leaves then matches the distribution that
we see in actual raindrops.
So those, the fragments, the shrapnel that lands on us,
doesn't go through the balloon process. Again.
It looks like it. And they argue just on the basis of the timescales,
that there isn't time that you can figure out the amount of time.
It takes a raindrop to fall to the ground and then sort of do some calculations
as to how quickly it should grow. And the answer is it does,
it just doesn't have time to go through that cycle. Again.
Mike,
it feels like this ballooning and traditional process would happen so quickly.
And cloud seems so high up in the sky that you'd feel like this would go through
lots of iterations, but, but no.
I think the issue is that in a cloud, you have a lot of water vapor,
which means that actually things can happen very quickly by the time that things
are in that. So this sort of fall phase, there isn't that much water around.
So the chances of things bumping into each other are much lower.
The chances of more water accreting onto your dropper, much lower.
So there just isn't time for these processes to happen.
They happen quite quickly in the clouds because it's just a lot of water there,
but by the time the things are falling, there's lots of gaps between the water.
And so it doesn't happen again.
Well,
I thought the shrapnel pieces would have the chance to go through the balloon
process or are they too small for that now?
No. So they are now back in this regime where the,
the surface tension is the winning force so that they will then turn back into
these more or less verical things.
So the raindrops which fall on your head probably are more or less round.
Hi everyone, professor Mike Merrifield, are you just watching this video? Well,
he's an astronomer.
You can see even more of his videos here on 60 symbols or our special astronomy
channel, deep sky videos. There are links on the screen and in the description,
of course, but Mike's also become the unofficial weatherman of 60 symbols.
He's done videos on lightning, rainbows and clouds.
There's a whole playlist. Again,
there's a link on the screen and down in the description.